lie too like they think that if they've
been married 18 years they have three
kids that if he cheats that they're okay
I'm Gonna Leave the marriage that might
not be the smartest thing to do that
might be something that you need to go
to couples counseling over or you need
to burn it down according to Modern
women who cares they'll just be screwed
screw the kids no just burn it burn it
down 20 years one night yeah over quick
question though yeah question what is
cheating
and the reason why I asked that yeah is
because
if a man has no if a man doesn't sleep
with another man's wife and he's just
sleeping with another woman just to get
a nut off is that cheating
he has to go in yeah I feel like it has
to go it matters because it matters
because if we're gonna differ if you're
gonna Define cheating I think we want
men to have options right
so if a man just uses a woman just this
is gonna sound bad but for ejaculating
purposes only and he doesn't sleep with
another man's wife
and he comes back to his his main wife
and he does all the things he's supposed
to do as a husband as a father or
whatever
what's the cram I mean there's two
things one obviously a lot of men say oh
she was better than my hand I've heard
that a lot I've had that on this screen
so that so men's that's a different case
but I don't see the the I don't
understand the point of why does it have
to not be someone else's wife why does
someone else's relationship impact mine
because at the end of the day if you are
sleeping with someone just for sex and
the other person wants to if she's gonna
cheat she's gonna cheat so it doesn't
really matter if it's another man's wife
or not in that case well historically it
has mattered actually so I mean there's
lots of cultures that have had you know
rules laws legislation about infidelity
and what that looks like and in the past
like men men have had the opportunity to
to cheat from like a Christian context
if it wasn't another man's wife so I
understand what you're saying but it's
like it's 2022 I don't think people are
really putting standards on any type of
cheating it's just like you know
whatever whatever goes down goes down
but I I know what you mean it probably
would be worse if you were you know
being in some other guy's wife well I
don't think you'd want to risk your life
like that so do you think women are
mentioning the same thing no no but
there I think there's reasons that women
cheat that men don't want to hear about
um like you know we're looking for
something we're looking for that
intimacy or that closeness and we might
feel ignored it's just that women have
to understand you know context of the
situation if you're you know a
stay-at-home wife your man's working 60
hours a week yeah you're gonna feel
lonely oh no it doesn't mean that you go
sleep with the neighbor it means that
you try to you try to hit him up when he
comes home from work but not too soon
you gotta be quiet first yeah yeah 30
minutes 30 minutes maybe give them 45.
so females are doing it genuinely for a
void uh it depends because you know we
got these city girls so they're
something else I'm just speaking from
like there are times where good women do
end up feeling like compelled to cheat I
know that that sounds weird to you guys
but if it's just like problem after
problem after problem I feel like my
husband doesn't notice me yeah you might
start looking elsewhere for it but I
think women women cheat emotionally but
it's interesting too
um so like I think there's different
standards too because I don't know that
I'd care that much if my husband slept
with another woman I realized oh no like
the internet's gonna be like but you're
a Christian look there's there's like
reasons for this but um I think I would
be offended if this man was accepting
another woman's phone calls and she was
like crying on the phone venting her
emotions to him I'd be like oh no or if
he was like taking her out on dates and
spending a bunch of money I'd be like
this is not right this is unjust how
could you do this to me shooting
emotions like a completely different
thing yeah if I've got one wife and I'm
already doing that for her there is no
way I'm doing that for another one I
mean the entire point is the entire
point of actually doing those things and
actually dealing with a woman's emotions
is because you actually want that woman
in the form of a relationship you want
her to be yours because she's a threat
because you like her personality exactly
and that's that's where that's where it
gets a bit weird because men normally
only cheat physically because they need
a variety it's like food if you eat
lasagna every day for the rest of your
life you might get bored of it so if it
but if you alternate between like
lasagna Pizza like lobster yeah so I
guess I just choose not to be in a
relationship with women that are that
hungry I have a question is there such
thing as a woman doing too much
yeah I've just heard the phrase she does
too much or don't do too much well in
terms of that oh she's just forcing it
without doing the most yeah yeah yeah
so guys so guys point of view what does
that mean I didn't stress or can I have
an example annoying me
no I think you think she means like
female simping
yeah I know but that's that's only
because
[Music]
to the moon and back we won't complain
if we want you if we don't want you stop
it I don't feel like you hear about it
so much in relationships like personally
anyway I don't think I've heard from
males like oh she's doing the most
you're doing too much in a relationship
it's pre that who gets like talking face
so what's what's too much in the talking
situationship courting whatever whatever
you want to call it in 2022 face
it forcing everything too quickly
especially if you don't really like or
you're just trying to figure things out
it's like when you're dating someone in
the beginning you always say I don't
know what I'm looking for I'm not
looking for anything because if it
doesn't amount to anything it didn't
amount to anything but amounts if if you
say oh yeah I'm looking for something
I'm looking for something and it doesn't
matter I think some somehow you're a
[ __ ] now so you know uh so that's
kind of just guys not wanting to be the
bad guy and it's getting open yeah yeah
because then she can't come to you later
and say you promise something that you
didn't I think like at the at the
talking stage
um a girl
coming up with like so what are we or
where's this going like a couple months
in I think that's doing too much
wait no well I disagree
depends how many marks in so how many
months
like um for me I've always said like
four seasons on the road trip
Four Seasons and a road trip yeah that's
how that's how long you kind of need to
that's that's how long you that's how
long you need to kind of know someone so
you talk to a girl you you do like the
situationship thing for a year if it's
going to be a situationship
um then yeah for a year before you kind
of decide whether you want to lock it
down or not okay roughly what do you
guys think is that if if you live
together if if like you if you spend a
lot of time together in each other's
yards and each other's places
um to the point where you borderline
living together than less than a year
maybe six months maybe six months so if
she asks you that at six months is it
doing too much no if if we were spending
a lot of time together within in that
six months like sleepovers yeah
so you mean you mean having sex though
not just no but sleepovers literally
sleep and like waking up with each other
like you know I'm saying seeing seeing
each other's lives and that if it's like
that then six months is okay but if it's
not like that and it's a situationship
where you you don't spend too much time
together like that then yeah you need
you need you need at least a year like
for me I don't really like the phrase
like doing too much and doing them
because as as males I feel sometimes you
have to have a level of like
accountability so we'll say oh we don't
want a girl to have x amount of bodies
whatever it be six seven bodies so in
one hand we're saying this
and then in one hand we're saying when
she wants to take it to the next level r
she's doing too much when she's asking
the question but we full well know if
that she's had as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we
monetized on a daily
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible